WE'VE BEEN ASKING THE NAME
QUESTIONS ALL MORNING LONG.
I'LL ASK IT BECAUSE WE'RE DYING
TO KNOW, SIRI, WHO IS THE VOICE
OF SIRI?
>> I AM THE VOICE OF SIRI.
>> I COULD HAVE GOTTEN CHILLS.
HER NAME IS SUSAN BENNETT.
LET'S ASK HER QUESTIONS.
WHY IS ONE FOOT LONGER THAN THE
OTHER?
SIRI, WHAT IS THE DRIVING TIME
FROM NEW YORK TO L.A.?
SIRI, ARE YOU HAPPY TO BE HERE
THIS MORNING?
>> I AM SEA SORRY, MICHAELA, I
CANNOT ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS.
>> REALLY COOL, WHAT A DELIGHT
TO MEET.
>> THANK YOU, NICE TO BE HERE.
>> HOW LONG DID YOU GET THE
VOICEOVER GIG FOR THE APPLE
ICON?
>> THIS HAPPENED IN 2005 BEFORE
ANYONE EVER THOUGHT ABOUT AN
iPHONE.
I TAKE THAT BACK, STEVE JOBS
SURE THOUGHT OF IT.
THE ORIGINAL WERE TEXT TO SPEECH
VOICES, WHOLE MONTH OF JULY
2005, I WAS SPEAKING ALL KINDS
OF CRAZY SENTENCES.
>> HOW MANY WORDS OR LINES DO
YOU RECORD?
I'VE ASKED SIRI ALMOST
EVERYTHING AND GOTTEN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT ANSWERS.
>> PEOPLE THINK THEY CAME UP
WITH THE PHRASES THAT SHE SPEAKS
ORIGINALLY, BUT ORIGINALLY IT
WAS JUST A BUNCH OF SENTENCES
AND PHRASES THAT WERE CREATED SO
THAT EVERY SINGLE COMBINATION OF
VOWELS AND CONSONANTS AND
SYLLABLES COULD BE SPOKEN.
>> PIECED TOGETHER AND THIS IS
SORT OF A TYPICAL WAY OF
VOICEOVER YOU'RE A WORKING
VOICEOVER ARTIST AND THESE ARE
THE RECORDINGS THAT DO YOU.
DID THIS ONE SEEM DIFFERENT?
DID YOU HAVE A SENSE IT WOULD
BECOME THE CULTURAL PHENOMENON
OR CRUTCH?
>> THIS WAS NOT TYPICAL BECAUSE
I'VE MOSTLY DONE A LOT OF RADIO
AND TELEVISION COMMERCIALS AND
NARRATIONS AND ALL THAT KIND OF
THING.
NO, IT WAS SOMETHING VERY
DIFFERENT.
WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE THE
TEXT-TO-SPEECH I DID SOMETHING
FOR LUCENT TECHNOLOGIES, AND
THEY HAD ME WEARING THIS THING
CALLED A LARYGIOGRAPH THAT WAS
AROUND MY NECK.
>> SOUNDS TERRIBLE.
>> I FOUND IS FASCINATING, I
SAID I'M IN.
LUCENT WENT AWAY AND THAT NEVER
HAPPENED BUT EVENTUALLY THEY DID
THE TEXT-TO-SPEECH AND OF COURSE
BACK IN THAT DAY WE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY CLUE BACK THEN IT SOUNDED
LIKE THIS, IT WAS ROBOTIC AND
HARD TO IMAGINE THAT IN JUST SIX
YEARS IT WOULD HAVE SMOOTHED OUT
TO THE POINT THAT --
>> HOW OFTEN DO YOU